tiens c'est pourquoi faire tout ça salut
casimir pardon bonjour julie c'est
pourquoi faire tout ça pour manger et
par qui ben par tulu par les enfants par
toi par françois par mois par tous ceux
qui en voudront mais alors c'est une
fête
titi veut elle qu'est ce que tu fais
rien du tout comment ça je ne sais rien
du tout mais c'est impossible
pourquoi mais quand on organise une fête
c'est pour fêter quelque chose
écoute tu vas comprendre j'aime dit
surpris ouais ouais
et ben moi je trouve que c'est très
important les surprises dans la vie par
exemple offrir un beau bouquet de fleurs
à sa maman sans attendre le jour de son
anniversaire c'est une vraie surprise
je trouve ça beaucoup plus gentil c'est
bien vrai et bien aujourd'hui je fais
une fête comme ça sans raison
et bien moi j'ai une idée laquelle et
bien si pour cette fête on faisait une
danse oui alors alors ce aujourd'hui on
apprend visant on fait ce qu'on veut
d'accord mais avec nouvelles musiques
entendues
[Musique]
et
c
m
[Musique]
et
c'est
[Musique]
et
e
allez
[Musique]
car à julie je crois que ça suffit comme
ça hein c'était pas mal à notre d'or ce
cas là aussi bien amusé ça m'a donné
très fin si on mange à quelque chose
alors pas encore il faut attendre que
tout le monde soit l'heure c'est dommage
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans cette boîte et
ne tarte aux prunes une tarte aux prunes
j'adore la tarte aux prunes mais
attention casimir il n'y a ni au choix
ni cornichons nice aussi son rap et oui
mais ça ne fait rien la tarte aux prunes
est le seul gâteau que j'adore sans rien
ajouter
alors est-ce qu'on peut l'ouvrir non non
je ne sortirais que lorsque tout le
reste aura été mangés au mais moi je
préfère la tarte aux prunes beaucoup de
casimir fait pas tant d'enfants gâtés
regarde tout ce qui est moins bouché
willemez commence par là j'ai craint
enfin bon je vais chercher les autres et
je te permets en attendant de commencer
bon moi y envoyons saucisson
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
julie nous a fait bon venir est déjà là
d'ailleurs révélé que ce qui s'est passé
tu m'avais demandé de commencer on voit
que l'injure casimir tu as tout manger
il nous reste plus qu une rondelle de
saucisson par personne
casimir c'est vraiment pas très gentil
pour les autres ça mais j'avais
tellement faim
c'est peu heureusement que j'ai gardées
en réserve la tarte aux prunes notamment
florent des contrôles médicaux casimir
j'ai compris tu as tout manger pour être
sûrs que nous entamerions la part
tomberait dessus ni tu as raison julie
mais je suis bien punis pourquoi parce
que j'ai tellement mangé que je n'ai
plus faim du tout tiers deux ténors
[Musique]